[Music]  welcome home mrs. Cameron oh stop my  name is mr. Conover I'm just practicing  welcome to the neighborhood thank you I  hope you'll be happy here  Santa Julia hi Julie bye Lily say bye to  mommy I Spader it's time to tell Tessa  and Lily that we're getting married  [Music]  how well do you really know Julia she  has no idea how to parent toughie  come on Lily  Tesla said that she found Lilly talking  to some guy what guy she seemed to think  that you knew him who was the man you  were talking to at the market what man  I'm scared you're not getting off this  horse come on Lilly I'm sorry who asked  you  we're leaving you only get one mother  Lilly don't ever forget that  where's your ring how come you have  malaria  who sent you flowers she's messing with  me David enough is enough  are you threatening me yes she is  dangerous she needs to stay away from  all of us  brother it's my life not yours  [Music]  and he met you that Oh Julia hi Julia  that Lilly say bye to mommy